Buttered by critics upon the release of
its first season in 2017 Marvel's Iron
Fist needed some serious image
rehabilitation going into its offer more
outing but the show's reception and
quality actually has started to turn
around and it's even set a Rotten
Tomatoes record in the process according
to the breakdown of data by the review
aggregating site
iein faced a set a record for the
biggest jump in quality between the
first and second seasons of a TV series
at Rotten Tomatoes has ever measured
just because iron fist has clearly
improved doesn't mean this show is
suddenly great now according to the
second season's breakdown on the website
only 50% of critics across 30 reviews
Dinah's series as being worth another
look on an A to F scale that's still a
failing grade though it's definitely a
big improvement over the first season's
19% score when iron fist first season
was released in 2017 critics too righted
the show as being one of the single
worst properties Marvel television had
yet produced it was a feat which to this
date has been exceeded only by ABC's
inhuman series which was released the
same year to a 12 percent Rotten
Tomatoes score despite the major second
season bump from critics it's hard to
characterize iron fist as being a
must-see series yet the finding is
mostly encouraging for viewers who are
already fans of the show with the second
season having a little more of what
people like and a little less of what
they don't
unlike Hannibal or Breaking Bad series
which started good and then got even
better I am first started off terribly
and is now more or less okay even the
more negative reviews for this series
are now characterizing the show as being
fine mildly entertaining or merely
boring
in other words iron fist has stood on
exactly appointment of viewing but it
probably won't ruin your day to see an
episode anymore partially explaining the
turnaround in quality is the fact that
iron fist second season was written
under the guidance of a new showrunner
Raven Metzner
as a screenwriter and producer Metzner
previously worked on the TV series
Sleepy Hollow as well as the show's
heroes reborn falling skies and daybreak
he also wrote the screenplay for the
movie Elektra but that was a long time
ago so we'll try and ignore that Meza
came on board iron fist as a replacement
for season 1 showrunner Scott Burke
who'd earn himself a questionable
reputation as a show run
after overseeing the Showtime serial
killer series texture at the fell from
prestige drama into self-parody
he was also the showrunner for marbles
and humans which was quietly cancelled
after eight profoundly bad episodes
alongside the behind-the-scenes
personnel shifts iron fist second season
also saw marked improvements to a
cinematography and fight choreography
which are generally regarded as being
pretty important ingredients for a
martial arts superhero show the new
season also included an increased focus
on the characters misty Nights and
Colleen Wayne better known in Marvel
Comics as the daughters of the Dragon
season to seize the fighters spend some
time teaming up taking on the bad guys
to enjoyable effect misty also gets a
spiffy new robotic arm while Colleen
earns herself some impressive new powers
in short while iron fist has still the
lowest rated series in the Marvel
Netflix collection it significantly
closed the gap in quality between itself
and the other five shows unfortunately
iron fist second season still seems to
struggle with the same issues that
affect all the shows at Marvel's Netflix
universe whether it's daredevil Jessica
Jones Luke Cage or the Punisher every
one of Marvel's streaming series has
been critiqued to some extent and iron
fist is no exception it still suffers
from problematic pacing some aimless
subplots and occasionally subpar
production values but the season as a
whole is a big step in the right
direction now that iron fist is
watchable maybe it's time to tweak and
retool all the series and finally unlock
the full potential of this corner of the
Marvel Universe
[Music]